good evening my fellow Americans
you remember my anger translator Luther
Wow
hello now I've told Luther that he can
join me for this last address but that
his being on his very best behavior is
crucial to healing the divide in this
country
peachy Luther go against every natural
instinct in your body since we last
spoke the country is voted for a new
president true we all have to accept
that and as someone else calling the
shots was a close election but the
people have spoken out bulls it's more
imperative than ever that we move on as
a country United you can't stand
each other even as the country adopts
new policies on at rate immigration
policy plagiarize our speeches I said B
I have greatly enjoyed my time as your
president except when I'm you know all
my own when the Republicans would let me
do and in that one dude said I
wasn't born here and then y'all elected
him so you know didn't love that part so
much so pretty much the beginning middle
and
I have met with president-elect Trump
and have pledged my support in his
transition he doesn't the job y'all I
saw it in his eyes the dude was shook
the only reason he ran is because his
factory in China has made too many red
hats I assure you that if he succeeds we
all succeed unless you succeed with all
the shitty promise to succeed with in
that case and now a time cherished
tradition is that the outgoing that's me
leaves the incoming president a little
note in the desk of the Oval Office of
course it's completely confidential
go yourself till now oh that's my
bad so all of you out there who are
afraid that your way of life is under
attack
remember that progress isn't always a
straight line no cuz sometimes it's a
line that goes like this goes down stay
strong and never stop standing up for
what you believe it yes I would like to
book a four year stay for five at the
Ice Hotel in Sweden please sorry five
for both I mean y'all we're gonna take
bow make it six
in summation thanks America it's been
real it's been good but it ain't been
real good apparently is the new black
good luck with the healthcare assholes
mo peace
I got my eye on you grabber
[Music]